oggi cuciniamo la trota ghiacciata
importante è un procedimento molto
antico Prima di tutto prendiamo la
nostra trota tagliamo a metà la trota
per lungo stavolta Attenzione ragazzi
una volta posizionata va messa sul
fornello
Perry night nel mentre tagliamo la zucca
è lo zenzero in più parti possibili Eh
andiamo a prendere la nostra trota che
se nel frattempo si è cotta grigliata
Tutto quello che lei con delicatezza
Attenzione ragazzi prendiamo lo zenzero
che abbiamo tagliato lo mettiamo andiamo
a prendere un po' di vino perché questo
piatto ha un retrogusto di vino Eh lo
mettiamo qua Perfetto La Trota
ghiacciata perché ghiacciata l'abbiamo
grigliata quindi è strano ingrediente
segreto cosà Mia nonna era proprio ehm
l'estintore sopra il piatto per dare
Giusto quel tocco di
Bass cioè proprio solo un pizzichino
Dopodiché il piatto è pronto per essere
servito ma come sempre ragazzi la fotina
di rito Mamma mia come sempre Seguitemi
per altre ricette